ladies and gentlemen hier spricht eure
Flugbegleitung Vanessa schnallt euch an
denn es gibt heute den
Motel miio Adventskalender und da fühlen
wir uns doch glatt als ob wir persönlich
nach Portugal geflogen sind mit diesen
tollen Produkten das Motel amio einen
Adventskalender rausgebracht hat ist ein
Zeichen von Gott ich mich auf dem
richtigen Pfade
befinde denn Motel amio sind für mich
wirklich die schönsten tassent Teller
und so Wohnaccessoires die es gibt ich
habe sogar voll viel bei mutella Mio
gekauft als ich beim perfekten
Promidinner mitgemacht habe weil die
einfach so schön sind und ich bin so
stolz dass ich jetzt sagen kann dieses
Video ist gesponsert und jetzt alle
dieses Video ist
gesponsort denn Motel amio hat mir
diesen Adventskalender zu zugeschickt
aber als Disclaimer möchte ich sagen
alles was ich über die Produkte sage das
sind wirklich meine Worte mir wurde
nichts vorher gegeben außer dass ich
wirklich erwähnen muss dass dieser
Kalender streng limitiert ist also der
wird nicht lange da sein schlagen Sie
jetzt zu bevor es zu spät ist es ist
einfach mutella mi Adventskalender er
kommt heute raus das heißt wenn ihr ih
wirklich gerne haben wollt geht jetzt
mal unten in die Videobeschreibung da
findet ihr den Link zu diesem Kalender V
allem ziehen wir ja bald in unsere und
dann passt es einfach so perfekt wir
haben es hier natürlich auch wegen der
Produkte mit einem preisspieligeren
Adventskalender zu tun
299 € kostet der und soll einen wahen
Wert von
453 haben das finden wir schon mal
fantastisch es gibt auch ein kleinen
Rabattcode den ich vom mutellaam
bekommene und jetzt machen wir diesen
riesigen Schuhkarton auf Schuhkarton
guckt mal der ist so stylisch bin
einfach Fan was soll ich sagen ich weiß
nicht ob das eine gute Idee ist den so
hoch hoch zu haben aber vielleicht ja
nee ne aber mal gucken erster Eindruck
es ist ein sehr schwerer Adventskalender
Design ist natürlich ziemlich
unweihnachtlich ehrlich gesagt also ja
typisch mellaam auch irgendwie von vom
Design ich bin ja Christmas Fan und
deswegen ich finde weihnachtliche Motive
oder irgendwas was weihnachtlich
aussieht immer schöner ist jetzt
vielleicht aber nicht für die gesamte
Zielgruppe von mutella Mio so deswegen
okay oh ich glaube den soll man soll man
den so aufstellen wir haben hier ein
erstes Problem wir haben hier ganz viele
Schachteln aber nicht die Nummer eins
ich glaube aber auch dass das nicht so
einfach ist mit diesem rausziehen weil
sonst fallen die halt runter und also
ich glaube es ist ein Chaos nee moment
mal das Design ist ja auch so gemacht
dass das halt so eigentlich da stehen
soll da wundert mich jetzt echt dass
tüche Nummer 1 halt nicht vorne ist ja
also diesen Kalender wird man auf jeden
Fall nicht so benutzen können wie er
hier reingepackt ist man muss die Teile
rausholen und sich selber
aufstellen ich hole jetzt mal alles raus
wir haben schon mal hier die eins ich
habe schon klimpern gehört ich kann mir
wirklich nicht so richtig vorstellen was
hier drin sein soll weil die haben ja
Teller Becher Gläser oh wird das lange
dauern die Türchen zu suchen ich flipp
aus ja wir fangen einfach mal an ich
habe jetzt hier hunderte von Kartons
Türchen Nummer ein mein Gott freue ich
mich cool in Türchen Nummer 1 das ist so
ein crazy Kalender oh mein Gott ist
diese Schale schön in Türchen Nummer ein
ist eine Schale eine pastaschale
servichale Suppenschale was auch immer
ihr damit machen wollt das ist für mich
eher so ein sommerliches Design aber man
benutzt sie auch das ganze Jahr über und
falls ihr mutella Mio nicht kennt und
nicht wisst warum ich so ausflippe das
ist alles so handgemacht in Portugal
also so handgetöpfert und da sieht man
dann immer den Stempel und man sieht
hier das ist halt ja das hat einen sehr
handgemachten we weil es auch
handgemacht ist und ich mag einfach
diesen Kontrast weil man z.B bei Ikea
möbelhoffner und wo nicht überall halt
so ja sehr gestampft und sehr
produzierte Dinge hat und die sind immer
halt so ein bisschen unique mellaam ich
bin euer Werbegesicht ich ma das mit
euch Türchen Nummer 2 oh m das ist so
toll ein Espresso Becher ich habe von
dieser Reihe zwei tiefe Teller und das
ist glaube ich auch mit meine
Lieblingsreihe wie cool das aussieht
hier mit diesen Drop drunter hier drin
so leicht blau WIS ihr dann ist hier so
sandig ich habe schon mal selber
getöpfert und es ist eigentlich auch
relativ einfach du hast halt dann dein
getöpferes und dann tungst du in so ein
Sandbad also es ist so ein sandiges
Wasser und da tungst du dann dein Becher
rein läs es einmal abtropfen bup und
dann wird das so gebrannt und dann
kriegt es halt die Farbe und den Glanz
oh oh oh die Preise ich muss natürlich
noch Preise rauss die Schale kostet 22 €
und der Espresso Becher ein Becher 12 €
aber Hand gemacht ne das ist der
Unterschied das ist halt Türchen Nummer
ne ja hallo ist das ein schöner Teller
ich glaub es einfach nicht dass hier so
Teller und sowas einfach drin sind in
dem
Adventskalender und falls jetzt denkt ja
aber Vanessa dann hat man so viele
verschiedene Designs und so das finde
ich aber gerade bei Motel amio so
passend dass weil alles so diesen
handgemachten Look hat und deswegen
passt das immer zusammen wenn man das
dann zusammen hinstellt ich habe z.B mir
zwei Becher aus einer Reihe geholt einen
Becher aus einer anderen Reihe weil man
braucht ja eigentlich nicht immer von
allem ein Set ich finde Sets von etwas
zu haben ist ganz schön wenn man so eine
Tafel einrichtet und dann irgendwie ja
Leute zum Essen da hat aber so für den
Alltag da brauchen man ja keine sechs
gleichen Becher dann holt man sich
lieber drei schöne die man die
unterschiedlich sind und die man
irgendwie alle drei schön findet als
alles so gleich zu haben deswegen toll
das ist jetzt hier eine schnitzeljack
Nummer vi dann holt man einfach im
Advent jeden Tag sowas krasses raus oh
ich kann nicht anders es tut mir leid
ich will nicht so übertrieben wirken ja
die haben mir den geschickt und ja
vielen Dank und so
aber der ist schöner als mein Leben das
ist der perfekte Teebecher re stop ich
hab schon wieder den Preis für den
Teller nicht gesagt der Teller hat 26 €
gekostet und die Tasse 18 € oh mein Gott
ich ich liebe diese Tasse ist so schön
ich habe sie mir im Laden schon mal
angeguckt und dann dachte ich so ja
vielleicht hole ich sie mir noch aber
jetzt habe ich sie ich weiß nicht was es
auch mit diesem Muster auf sich hat ich
meine deswegen sind sie wahrscheinlich
so erfolgreich weil das einfach so ein
schönes Design ist es fühlt sich auch
einfach echt hochwertig an muss ich
sagen war dann so eingeknuddelt in
seiner Decke oh ich trinke gerade mein
Tee ist wunderschön türche Nummer
5 von dieser Reihe habe ich schon zwei
Kaffeebecher geholt das ist auch mit
meine Lieblingsreihe die andere und die
hier sind glaube ich meine
lieblingsdesigns also wenn ich so
mehrere Teile von den holen würde würde
ich glaube ich auch den der Farbe das
holen das ist die cordoama ein
soßenschälchen klar wenn ich dann auf
dem Tisch mir eine Soße das ma ich dann
natürlich mein soßenschälchen rein ist
das schön oder jetzt sag doch mal was
kostest du 14 € okay doki es ist
Nikolaus wir gehen zu unserem
Adventskalender freuen uns denn Motel
amio hei das nolaus ist eine
Dose
ich hö auf ich versprech es ich hö jetzt
auf aber es ist eine
Dose Deckel das ist so toll das sieht
toll aus aber nicht so weihnachtlich 20
€ Nummer 7 natürlich brauchen wir noch
einen kleinen Teller 22 €. das ist von
der gleichen Reihe nicht so ganz wie der
Teller aber wie die Schüssel am Anfang
ich glaube das ist von der gleichen
Reihe wie die Schlüssel oder nee das ist
eigentlich wie der hier es ist bleibt
ein
räsel Nummer a ich kann schon mal sagen
es ist auf jeden Fall kein
weihnachtlicher Kalender auch die Farben
und so das ist auf jeden Fall nicht
jetzt Christmas Stimmung oh mein Gott
ist dieser Becher schön ist ein Kopper
Alto Becher klein ein Becher ohne Griff
muss ich ehrlich sagen habe ich noch nie
verstanden haben so viele Leute ich bin
jemand der ein Henkel braucht weil ich
so hitzeempfindlich bin ist das aber
eine tolle Farbe ne so ein richtig
schönes salbergrün 14 € kommen wir zu
Türchen Nummer 9 und Türchen Nummer 9
ist das beste Türchen warum weil es
meine Lieblingszahl ist und in Türchen
Nummer 9 ist drin eine komische Form bin
gespannt ich dachte schon Aschenbecher
ein
Eierbecher sehr sty man hat es im Leben
geschafft wenn man solche Eierbecher hat
12€ Nummer 10 ich bin sehr gespannt es
ist relativ
leicht oh mein Gott die habe ich
letztens noch im Laden sehen und dachte
ich hätte so gerne ein Küchentuch von
denen made with love in Portugal
Baumwolle und Leinen sehr gut für die
Küche in linen mit drin ist stylisch sch
mal vor bei euch hängt in der Küche so
ein Dings das sieht doch schon ganz
anders aus als dieses typische Muster ja
ich bin Fan ich entschuldige mich jetzt
auch nicht mehr dafür das ist wie beim
Sally Adventskalender ich liebe dich ich
liebe dich schon lange wisst ihr wenn
mir etwas gefällt dann gefällt es mir
und dann sage ich es auch 16 € ist ein
ini backt Nummer 11 und was lässt in
türche Nummer 11 mein tinewitlerherz
höher
schlagen noch eine Schale also ich sag
euch eine Sache ne ich mache jetzt seit
neuen eine neue Ernährungsweise und zwar
nenne ich das ich esse nur noch bowls
weil ich vor habe sehr viele Nährstoffe
zu essen und sehr gesund mich zu
ernähren was aber finde ich immer
schwierig ist wenn man Gerichte kochen
muss weil am Ende ja keine Ahnung ich
will halt viel verschiedenes Gemüse
essen und deswegen bereite ich immer
viel verschiedenes Gemüse zu und Pack
mir am Ende in einer Schüssel zusammen
und dann ist es ein bisschen wie so ein
bibinbab oder ja wie so eine Bowl halt
dafür brauche ich jetzt zurzeit so viele
Schüsseln weil ich da ma ich ein
bisschen Lauchzwiebeln rein oder ein
paar gerasbelte Karotten und dann Dings
und dann habe ich mal nicht genug
Schüsseln und für meine ich esse nur
Bowl Ernährungsweise ist das perfekt ein
miniellatief die Farbe ey guckt euch
doch mal wieder diese Farbe an das macht
Lust nach
Urlaub beim blau bin ich mir allerdings
nicht so sicher bei mir grün und rosa
finde ich super blau könnte ich meiner
Freundin geben die ist eher so ein blau
Nummer 12 Halbzeit wir sind bei türche
Nummer 12 angekommen und darin befindet
sich diese Serie lässt wirklich auch
mein Herz höher schlagen also ich wäre
nicht böse gewesen wenn nur dieses Set
drin gewesen wä oh das ist hier Mutter
und Kind kleine Espressotasse jetzt
stellt euch vor in eurem Schrank sind
das die Espressotassen die kleine
Schüssel natürlich num 11 hat 18 €
gekostet und 12 € für den Espresso ist
der toll mein Gott ist der toll uh
Nummer 13 ist groß ich frage mich aber
ob die das immer alles gleich haben oder
ob bei anderen vielleicht von ein
anderen Serie was drin ist könnten sie
ja schon
machen eine müslchale steht hier guckt
mal stell mal vor ihr macht da drin euen
Joghurt euer Müsli ein paar Früchte rein
ist do sofort Instagram Post jetzt hätte
ich gerne mal wieder was in rosa 14 ist
wieder ein ganz kleines
Paket noch ein Eierbecher für 12 ach so
22 € wir wollen ja eigentlich nie in
Adventskalender dass ich was doppelt
hier finde ich das gut dass ich was
doppelt weil dadurch hat man dann zwei
nein doch also für Timo und mich 15 ich
glaube hier wird ein Becher drin sein
mal
gucken es ist ein Teller ist das der
gleiche ach das ist ja krass hier hat
man dann zweimal den gleichen Teller was
wir in anderen Adventskalendern
vielleicht ein bisschen blöd finden
würden aber hier ist es super denn dann
hat man halt für Tim und m z.B zwei
Teller ach toll vielleicht hätten sie
das dann auch bei allen durchziehen
sollen dass sie immer zwei gleiche
reinmachen also dass man eigentlich 12
Gegenstände hat die sich aber immer
Doppeln und man dann halt von allem
immer zwei hat ja finde ich vielleicht
gar nicht so schlecht 22 € 16 wieder
ganz leicht bitte eine
küchenschütze ein Beutel
yes zählt es wenn ich sage dass dieser
Beutel besser ist als alle anderen
Beutel ich weiß ich bin sonst immer
nicht pro Beutel aber guckt wie hübsch
der ist guck mal wie gut der mir steht
ich find den ich find den sehr hübsch 12
€ Nummer 17 ist bestimmt ein großer
Teller noch ein XXL Becher wisst ihr was
als ich diesen Becher gesehen habe habe
ich mich einerseits gefreut dass ich
jetzt einen großen Becher habe den ich
super toll finde ich wusste aber dass
mir Timo den sofort wegnehmen wird weil
das die perfekte Größe für Tee hat und
jetzt habe ich einen zweiten und bin
sehr glücklich drüber 20 € oh Mensch
cool Check ist guck mal jetzt gibt's von
denen das Set und von denen das Set und
was in der 18 drin ist seht ihr wenn das
Licht
[Musik]
angeht cool die finde ich halt auch mega
cool Seifenschalen ich weiß n nicht
warum da kein Unterteller ist ich weiß
aber auch nicht ob ein Unterteller
überhaupt hingehört vielleicht ist das
hygienischer wenn das da unten einfach
ablaufen kann se ich eigentlich laschfan
bin benutze ich laschseifen und also da
wird meine lchseife doch fantastisch
drin aussehen und für 18 € könnte deine
lchseife dort auch Fantas Aussehen
schlagen Sie jetzt zu Nummer 19 ist groß
ich wette dass ich schon
weiß vom gleichen Design haben sie noch
mal diesen Teller reingepackt das macht
einfach Sinn da hast du zweimal den
Teller das ist doch schön für 26 € das
sieht ja toll aus guck doch mal ich kann
hier selber Mella Mio aufmachen Leute
ich sag wie es ist es ist einfach
Weihnachten gerade für mich 20 wir sind
wir sind in unseren 20ern angekommen und
haben für unsere Schüssel noch die
passende soßenschale das war eine
soßenschale oder für 14 € könnte das
deine sein toll
21 man ich bin auch einfach dafür
gemacht ach guckt euch das
doch
süß sieht das nicht schön aus was ist
das überhaupt ein Milchkännchen
natürlich wenn du zu Hause spontan
Kaffee aufmachen möchtest und deinem
Gast zu seinem Kaffee dann so ein
kleines Milchkännchen noch hinstellst
füllst die rein sagst du dann füll dir
rein wie viel du brauchst € Nummer
22 oh von den wollte ich immer eins
haben war zu geizig dafür ja das ist von
dieser Dings aber irgendwie sieht das in
diesem Licht so hat so ein
grünstichartig was ist das eigentlich
was ist das den Servierplatte 18 € oh
wir sind schon beim vorletzten
Türchen oh mein Gott ist das schön Kopa
Alto Becher klein dieses Design hat mein
Herz erobert ich könnte weinen so schön
finde ich den das ist einfach angenehm
anzuschauen eine tolle Ergänzung zu dem
Türchen Nummer 24 es ist Weihnachten
dein Küchenschrank sieht jetzt
mittlerweile sehr überfüllt aus und du
weißt du musst alte Sachen aussortieren
sonst platzt das aus allen näen aber
keine Sorge du gehst zum 24 Türchen weil
jetzt juckt dich das eigentlich noch
nicht so wirklich und du machst es auf
ja und du
kriegst das butterdöschen was du dir
schon immer erträumt hast ich liebe es
ich liebe es ich wollte eigentlich das
haben dann hat mir Timos Mama ein
anderes geschenkt was ihr vielleicht
schon gesehen hab da steht so Butter bei
die Fische drauf und es ist auch sehr
hübsch es ist sehr hübsch aber ich
wollte immer so eins haben es sieht doch
aus als frisch aus der Küche von deiner
Oma weggelaufen wäre und das so von 1950
noch ist und deine Oma hat es immer gut
behandelt deswegen hat das noch
überhaupt keinen Kratzer die SEER
Butterdose mintcent für 49 € schön
hörmer hörmer schön war Wert von 453 €
das stimmt das ist toll okay auch wenn
es kaum möglich ist versuche ich jetzt
eine halbwegs objektive Meinung zu
treffen ich finde die Produkte sehr gut
von der Qualität sie sind wirklich super
hochwertig toll verarbeitet tolle
Einzelstücke richtiger Hingucker in der
Küche ich verstehe nicht warum sich bei
der Butterdose für so ein cleanes Design
entschieden haben wo alle anderen
Produkte dieses Meeres verfrauschte
Dings und so haben das sieht aus als
diese Butterdose nicht zu mutellam
gehört und nicht zu diesem ganzen
Konzept das ist komisch ich bin auch
froh dass hier so kleine Sachen drin
sind wie diee servierschalen die
Eierbecher finde ich schön das einzige
Manko ist dass dir die Designs ja alle
irgendwie gefallen müssen und das ist
natürlich das schwierige weil bei Motel
amio habe ich Designs die finde ich
wunderschön und andere die ich natürlich
weniger schön finde als meine Favoriten
und da ist es natürlich dann schade wenn
du das auspackst und es ist nicht oder
ist es eins was du am wenigsten magst
wenn jetzt z.B keine Ahnung rosateller
wären jetzt mein Favorit gewesen so es
ist jetzt ein lustiger Zufall dass ich
diese Designs schon habe darauf muss man
sich glaube ich einstellen ansonsten ja
wä es vielleicht noch eine Idee gewesen
dass man verschiedene Kalender anbietet
aber ich glaube das ist deren erster
Adventskalender und da kann man ja jetzt
nicht auch gleich mit 100 verschiedenen
Arten von Adventskalendern rauskommen
und ansonsten verschenkt man dann halt
das was man nicht so gerne hat ne aber
ganz ehrlich die sind alle wunderschön
und ich freue mich über jedes Teil was
ich habe also klar auch wenn es nicht so
jetzt mein Favorit ist ist es trotzdem
hübsch und das ist mein fazit Ich
findande der lohnt sich gerade wenn man
motella Mio Fan ist so wie ich dann ist
das halt nobrainer und jetzt noch mal
zum Rabattcode mit Kalender Vanessa
bekommt ihr 20% im Onlineshop außer auf
Gutscheine die verao Kollektion und den
Adventskalender obviously und ihr kriegt
plus 5% auf die bereits bis zu 30%
reduzierten Sets wenn man was im Set
kauft dann wird's ja günstiger und da
gibt's noch mal plus 5% drauf aber alle
Infos und den Link findet ihr unten in
der Videobeschreibung jetzt gehe ich mal
alles abwaschen und in meinen Schrank
tun vielen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit
habe ich schon mal gesagt dass ich
meinen Job liebe bis dann tschüss